>>> SO MITCH McCONNELL IS IN HOT
WATER WITH MEMBERS OF HIS OWN
PARTY AFTER HELPING TO PUSH
THROUGH A SERIES OF LEGISLATIVE
VICTORY FOR JOE BIDEN.
WHILE FORMERLY NICKNAMED THE
GRIMM REAPER FOR SHUTTING DOWN
DEMOCRATIC LEGISLATION,
McCONNELL IS NOW AT ODDS WITH
HOUSE GOP LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
JOINING US NOW IS CNN'S MELANIE
ZANONA, SHE BROKE THIS STORY,
AND CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR,
S.E. CUPP.
TELL US WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE,
MELANIE?
>> Reporter: SO MITCH McCONNELL
USED TO HAVE THIS REPUTATION AS
THE GRIM REAPER, BECAUSE HE WAS
KNOWN FOR KILLING DEMOCRATIC
LEGISLATION AND KEEPING HIS
CONFERENCE TOGETHER, BUT LATELY,
MITCH McCONNELL HAS BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR KEEPING SOME OF
THESE KEY BIPARTISAN VICTORIES
ALIVE THAT DEMOCRATS ARE NOW
TOUTING ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
LAST YEAR, HE VOTED FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL.
EARLIER THIS SUMMER, HE VOTED
FOR GUN REFORM.
AND JUST THIS WEEK, HE SUPPORTED
A BILL THAT WOULD INCREASE CHIP
MANUFACTURING AND MAKE THE U.S.
MAR COMPETITIVE WITH CHINA.
AND SO THAT HAS REALLY PUT HIM
AT ODDS WITH HIS OWN PARTY.
IT HAS ESPECIALLY PUT HIM AT
ODDS WITH HOUSE GOP LEADER,
KEVIN McCARTHY, HIS COUNTERPART
IN THE LOWER CHAMBER, AND IT'S
CREATED SOME FRUSTRATION AND
TENSION AMONG REPUBLICANS,
ESPECIALLY IN THE HOUSE, WHO
WANT TO SEE SENATORS FIGHTING
TOUGHER.
BUT LOOK, SOME OF HIS ALLIES,
McCONNELL'S ALLIES, SAY THAT
THERE IS A METHOD TO HIS
MADNESS.
THAT HE WANTS TO PROVE THAT THE
SENATE CAN STILL WORK.
AND PERHAPS MORE IMPORTANTLY,
WANTS TO SHOW MIDDLE AMERICA
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE JUST NOT
REFLEXIVELY CLOSED TO MIDDLE OF
THE ROAD LEGISLATION, ESPECIALLY
ON AN ISSUE LIKE GUN REFORM.
AND SO HE IS FACING A MUCH
TOUGHER BATTLEGROUND IN THE
SENATE THAN IN THE HOUSE.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT CALCULATIONS
BETWEEN KEVIN McCARTHY AND MITCH
McCONNELL.
BUT IT IS STILL NOTABLE TO SEE
HOW DIFFERENTLY THEY APPROACH
EVERYTHING FROM POLITICS TO
POLICY, ESPECIALLY ON THE ISSUE
OF DONALD TRUMP.
THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT WHEN IT
COMES TO HOW THEY'VE TREATED THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
THAT COULD BECOME EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED IF THEY'RE IN THE
MAJORITY NEXT YEAR.
>> S.E., THERE'S, I GUESS, THE
SUBSTANCE AND THE SOAP OPERA OF
THIS.
LET'S START WITH THE SOAP OPERA,
SHALL WE?
>> PLEASE.
ALWAYS.
SO McCARTY/McCONNELL, WHO WINS?
>> WELL, I THINK SO IT'S FAIR TO
SAY MITCH McCONNELL IS IN A MUCH
BETTER POSITION.
HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S DOING.
THERE ISN'T NO REASON FOR WHY
HE'S PICKING THESE FIGHTS, AS
MELANIE INDICATED.
MITCH McCONNELL, "A," WANTS TO
PRESERVE THE FILIBUSTER.
"B," WANTS TO AT LEAST TO APPEAR
TO BE A WORKING PARTNER.
TO SHOW THAT HE CAN GET SOME
STUFF DONE, AND THAT ALLOWS HIM
TO OBJECT TO OTHER STUFF.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, HE WANTS
TO REGAIN THE MAJORITY.
AND STUFF LIKE THE GUN
LEGISLATION, HE HEARD FROM
SUBURBAN VOTERS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY THAT THEY WERE REALLY
UPSET ABOUT THE RISE IN MASS
SHOOTINGS.
SO HE'S PLAYING THAT GAME.
THE GAME IN THE HOUSE, AND KEVIN
McCARTHY'S REAL MOTIVATION ONLY
SEEMS TO BE, OWN THE LIBS.
DON'T EVER SUPPORT ANYTHING IF
IT WILL POLITICALLY ADVANTAGE
DEMOCRATS, EVEN IF IT WILL
ADVANTAGE VOTERS.
IT'S A GROSSER GAME, BUT THAT'S
WHERE KEVIN McCARTHY SEEMS TO
BE.
>> SPEAKING OF THE GAME, THE
GAME NORMALLY WITH MITCH
McCONNELL IS CHESS, AND WITH
KEVIN McCARTHY, IT'S MORE LIKE
TIC TAC TOE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SAYING, BRI,
HE'S JUST NOT AS GOOD AT THIS?
>> IT'S JUST KNOWN.
MEL WILL TELL YOU, ON THE HILL,
MITCH McCONNELL IS KNOWN AS VERY
STRATEGIC AND KEVIN McCARTHY IS
NOT, MEL.
>> YEAH, BUT IT'S DIFFERENT IN
THE HOUSE AND IN THE SENATE.
IN THE SENATE, YOU HAVE PEOPLE
WHO REPRESENT STATEWIDE.
IN THE HOUSE, YOU HAVE THESE
GERRYMANDERED DISTRICTED.
YOU HAVE A CONFERENCE THAT IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY MORE
CONSERVATIVE.
FOR KEVIN McCARTHY, IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT GAME AND HE'S TRYING
TO BECOME SPEAKER NEXT YEAR AND
HE WILL NEED SUPPORT OF THE
CONSERVATIVE BASE AND OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THAT'S ALSO WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
HERE, WHEREAS MITCH McCONNELL IS
VERY SAFE IN HIS POSITION,
DESPITE TRUMP CALLING FOR PEOPLE
TO OUST HIM.
HE MAINTAINS A GOOD STANDING IN
THE CONFERENCE.
BUT NONETHELESS, THERE ARE
PEOPLE ALREADY JOCKEYING FOR HIS
POSITION ONCE HE DECIDES TO STEP
DOWN.
>> HE'S SAFE IN HIS POSITION
NOW, S.E.
THE SENATE MAKEUP IS CHANGING
ELECTION BY ELECTION ALSO.
AND DEPENDING ON WHO WINS IN
NOVEMBER, HE COULD HAVE PEOPLE
WHO LOOK A LOT MORE LIKE THE
ONES THAT KEVIN McCARTHY IS
DEALING WITH IN THE HOUSE.
>> DEFINITELY.
AND I THINK HE'S VERY AWARE OF
THAT.
AND SO REGAINING THE MAJORITY, I
THINK, FOR HIM, IS ABOUT HIS OWN
PRESERVATION, AS WELL AS, YOU
KNOW, THE SENATE AT LARGE AND
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
BUT HE'S AWARE THAT HE IS NOT
UNTOUCHABLE.
AND ESPECIALLY LOOKING DOWN THE
PIKE, WE'VE REPORTEDLY HEARD
THAT DONALD TRUMP WANTS TO PICK
A FIGHT WITH BOTH McCONNELL AND
McCARTHY, SO THAT HE'S THE MAIN
SHOW IN 2024 IN NOVEMBER.
SO, A LOT OF MOVING PIECES, A
LOT OF CHESS PIECES OR TIC TAC
TOE.
>> Xs AND Os.
>> I THINK THAT WAS KEVIN
McCARTHY CALLING RIGHT NOW.
WHO WAS CALLING?
>> GEE, I WONDER IF YOU THINK,
S.E., THIS NEW MANCHIN DEAL,
LET'S BE CLEAR, IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE 60 VOTES.
IT'S A BUDGET RECONCILIATION
PROCESS.
IF THEY WIN OVER KYRSTEN SINEMA
AND THEY HAVE THE 60 VOTES, IT'S
JUST A PARTY-LINE VOTE.
DOES THAT CHANGE ANYTHING?
IF BIDEN GETS THIS BIG VICTORY
WITH THIS CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THIS HEALTH CARE PACKAGE, DOES
THAT CHANGE HOW SOME REPUBLICANS
LOOK AT WHAT MITCH McCONNELL HAS
DONE AS SAYING, OKAY, NOW YOU'VE
JUST ADDED TO HIS LIST OF
VICTORIES?
>> YEAH, THAT'S DEFINITELY THE
CONCERN, NOT JUST IN THE HOUSE
AMONG REPUBLICANS LIKE KEVIN
McCARTHY, BUT EVEN SOME
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THE OPTICS OF
BIDEN WINNING.
I GUESS THE GOOD NEWS FOR
REPUBLICANS, IF YOU WANT TO BE
REAL CRASS ABOUT IT, IS THAT A
LOT OF THIS STUFF WON'T BE FELT
BY VOTERS FOR SOME TIME.
SO IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE GOING
TO FEEL IT IMMEDIATELY, LIKE A
STIMULUS CHECK.
AND THEN RUN OUT TO THE POLLS IN
NOVEMBER AND VOTE FOR DEMOCRATS.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME.
THAT'S TRICKY FOR DEMOCRATS WHO
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SELL THE
WINS, BUT, SURE, REPUBLICANS ARE
LOOKING AT THE POLITICS OF ALL
OF THIS, NOT JUST THE POLICY.
>> AND MEL, I DON'T WANT TO
LEAVE THIS HANGING OUT THERE,
FOR THIS LEGISLATION THAT
McCARTHY IS UPSET ABOUT, THERE
HAVE BEEN, AT LEAST, TEN
REPUBLICANS EVERY TIME WHO VOTED
FOR IT, BECAUSE PRESUMABLY, THEY
THINK IT'S GOOD FOR THEIR
CONSTITUENTS.
YOU KNOW, KEVIN McCARTHY CAN
ARGUE IT'S NOT, BUT THESE
REPUBLICANS THINK IT'S GOOD
LEGISLATION THEY'RE VOTING "YES"
ON.
>> CLEARLY, THAT'S PART OF THE
CALCULATION HERE, ESPECIALLY
McCONNELL KNOWS THIS.
HE'S GIVING COVER TO HIS MOST
VULNERABLE MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THESE DEALS, ON
EVERYTHING FROM GUNS TO
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THESE ARE POPULAR IN AMERICA,
THESE ARE POPULAR IN SUBURBAN
BATTLEGROUND DISTRICTS.
BUT IT'S INTERESTING THAT KEVIN
McCARTHY NOT ONLY OPPOSED SOME
OF THESE DEALS, BUT HE ACTIVELY
WHIPPED HIS MEMBERS TO OPPOSE
THEM.
IT GOES EVEN A STEP FURTHER THAN
HIM JUST OPPOSING IT HIMSELF.
BUT NONETHELESS, SOME OF HIS
MEMBERS DEFIED HIM AND VOTED
AGAINST THE WHIP COUNT ANYWAY
AND THEY CROSSED PARTY LINES IN
THE HOUSE TO JOIN WITH DEMOCRATS
IN SUPPORTING THESE BILLS.
BUT I THINK, PRIVATELY, KEVIN
McCARTHY HAS CUT THESE MEMBERS
SOME SLACK.
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE ANY
PUNISHMENT FOR CROSSING THEM,
BECAUSE HE KNOWS DEEP DOWN THIS
IS IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF THEM TO
WIN BACK THE MAJORITY.
>> MELANIE, GREAT REPORTING,
S.E., THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
COMMENTARY THIS MORNING.
GREAT TO SEE YOU BOTH.
>>> SO WE WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE JOE MANCHIN/CHUCK
SCHUMER DEAL, A DEAL THAT SENT
SHOCK WAVES ACROSS THE CAPITOL
THIS WEEK.
HOW WILL THIS BILL THAT DEALS
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE, AND HEALTH
CARE COSTS, DRUG PRICES, HOW
WILL IT AFFECT YOUR LIFE ON A
DAILY BASIS?
JOINING US NOW, CNN CHIEF
BUSINESS CORRESPONDENT,
CHRISTINE ROMANS.
ROMANS, THERE'S A LOT IN HERE.
>> YEAH.
THEY'VE BRANDED THIS THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT.
PRICE TAG, YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT
IT, $739 BILLION.
BUT WHAT'S IN IT?
HERE'S SOME OF WHAT'S SUPPOSED
TO PUT MONEY BACK IN THE POCKETS
OF PEOPLE WHO NEED IT MOST.
HISTORIC PRICE CAPS.
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
ALLOWING MEDICARE TO LIMIT
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES.
SENIORS AND PEOPLE ON DISABILITY
WOULD PAY NO MORE THAN $2,000 A
YEAR OUT OF POCKET FOR THE
PRESCRIPTIONS THEY BUY AT A
PHARMACY.
VERY BIG DEAL.
OBAMACARE SUBSIDIES.
PEOPLE BUYING INTO OBAMACARE
WOULD CONTINUE GETTING HELP
PAYING THEIR PREMIUMS.
THAT I WOULD PAY NO MORE THAN
8.5% OF THEIR INCOME, AND THAT'S
DOWN FROM ALMOST 10% BEFORE.
SOME COULD GET SUBSIDIES THAT
ELIMINATE THEIR PREMIUMS
ALTOGETHER.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO HELP PEOPLE
SAVE MONEY ON ENERGY COSTS.
TEN YEARS OF CREDITS FOR
HOMEOWNERS FOR THINGS LIKE
ROOFTOP SOLAR PANELS, AND TAX
BREAKS FOR BUYING AN ELECTRIC
CAR, UP TO $7,000 FOR A NEW ONE,
$4,000 FOR A USED EV.
THAT'S AN EXTENSION OF THAT, THE
INCOME LEVEL WOULD BE LOWERED.
THEY'RE TRYING TO TARGET PEOPLE
WHO REALLY NEED IT, INSTEAD OF
SPREADING MONEY AROUND TO
EVERYONE, WHICH WAS CRITICIZED
IN COVID STIMULUS.
>> ALL THAT, PLUS LARRY SUMMERS
TOLD US THAT HE THINKS THIS BILL
FIGHTS INFLATION.
AND INFLATION AFFECTS EVERYBODY.
>> YEP.
CHRISTINE ROMANS, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.